[Music]
on this Friday night
snowy states of emergency a monster
blizzard blasts Newfoundland and
Labrador this is like a hurricane during
a snowstorm the drastic measures to keep
people safe and where this storm is
headed next financial help on the way
for families of Canadian victims of
flight 752 plus a rare meeting Canada's
foreign minister face-to-face with his
Iranian counterpart and who is Patrick
Matthews the Canadian arrested by the
FBI we talked to the Winnipeg journalist
who exposed his neo-nazi connections and
a significant offer for a significant
other I don't drive being along a
billionaires hopes to make one woman
swoon to the moon
[Music]
global national with Donna freezin
good evening and thanks for joining us a
monster winter storm is blasting parts
of Newfoundland and Labrador tonight
locals say it's the worst they have seen
in years
heavy snow and hurricane-strength winds
have prompted states of emergency in a
number of communities including the
capital st. John's all businesses have
been ordered closed vehicles ordered off
the roads even snowplows have now been
pulled from the roads and are on standby
for emergencies only
this is how the fierce front looks from
above it is big and it is menacing the
snow has trapped people inside their
homes and all this happened fast this
time-lapse shows a car being almost
buried in six hours blizzard and wind
warnings are in effect for much of the
province there are multiple power
outages even camera crews have retreated
from the streets
raus Lord and what people are calling a
hurricane of a snow storm it's a drastic
declaration with snow falling at 10
centimeters an hour and up to 75
centimeters in the forecast
authorities in Newfoundland and Labrador
were forced to do something they haven't
done in decades right now the city's st.
John's in the state of emergency so you
know we're not gonna have any vehicles
on the road right now and all businesses
are closed we're asking everybody to
stay home you got a complete whiteout
here you know very low visibility if any
and you know certainly not a safe you
know excursion outside of your home
right now the state of emergency forced
one taxi company to take its vehicles
off the road for the first time in its
history from the look of abandoned
roadways most people stayed inside
voluntarily some are getting a jump on
shoveling to make less work when it's
all over those who did venture out were
stunned by the combination of heavy snow
and vicious winds that are already
gusting over 100 kilometres an hour this
is a bad one this is like a hurricane
during a snowstorm in my opinion at one
point I didn't see I could make it home
and I I hit it for home I was it was so
white around the outside of my vehicle I
couldn't see in front of me behind me
and I've been covering weather for over
20 years and this one
far the worst Saint John's had already
received 170 centimeters of snow in the
past month that's more than half its
average winter total meteorologists say
by the time this Blizzard ends it could
set records for amounts and/or wind
speeds police say they have officers
available for emergencies and the worst
might not be over wind gusts are
forecast to be at their highest this
evening up to 150 kilometres an hour
in coastal areas Ross lore Global News
Halifax
meteorologist Ross hull joins me now
Ross how long is this storm going to
last Donna this is a massive storm and
it is taking its time to move out of
Newfoundland
look at this radar satellite image the
outflow from this system so it's having
a huge impact a major impact on st.
John's heavy snow strong winds close to
40 centimeters already today could see
just as much for some areas tonight and
of course those blizzard conditions with
the reduced visibility this system does
start to pull out by tomorrow morning so
good riddance we've got another system
on the way for that very area Monday not
as intense but it will be intense
snowfall southern Manitoba
into parts of Ontario and Quebec where
this could be the largest snowfall the
biggest snowfall so far this winter
what's been a pretty tame winter so far
not the conditions across the prairies
this week frigid extreme cold still a
cold one today wondering when you're
going to see some relief well that cold
starts to move out as we head into the
weekend temperatures above the freezing
mark by Sunday in the next week across
southern Alberta so mild conditions
across the southern prairies but that
onshore flow for the south coast of BC
will mean some steady rain and the snow
that's already fallen there could melt
the combination of the two could lead to
some flooding Donna all right Ross hull
thank you
in other news the Prime Minister has
announced families of those who lost
loved ones in the downing of flight 7-5
to will get some financial health it's
not compensation that's up to Iran to
provide but it is designed to offer
short-term help
Abigail Beeman is in Ottawa with the
details Abigail what is the Canadian
government providing to the families
ladonna the Prime Minister is offering
$25,000 for each victim we know there
were 57 Canadian citizens on board that
plane but Justin Trudeau also shared
there were 29 permanent residents who
would be eligible for help - that adds
up to a little more than two million
dollars I've been meeting with families
over the past weeks I have had direct
conversations with them on the needs
they're facing and everything from bills
that are coming in to credit cards that
are maxed out to real questions about
how to get back to Iran to support their
families there or bring people over at a
time where air travel is increasingly
limited in the region and expensive the
Prime Minister was clear that these are
only first steps saying the families
need help now but that Canada expects
Iran to fully compensate them he says
it's too early to say what specifically
Canada will call for but that any money
Iran may hand over will go to families
and not to reimburse the Canadian
government we also learned from Trudeau
that about 20 families want their loved
ones buried in Canada and he expects
some of those repatriations to happen in
a matter of days Abigail and Canada's
Foreign Affairs Minister had a rare
meeting with iran's Foreign Minister
today what was the tone of that what was
discussed well Donna at this in-person
meeting Francois Philippe champagne
updated his Iranian counterpart on the
requests from the five foreign ministers
who agreed on a framework of action
after they met in London
Thursday those five requests include
full compensation for victims families
and an independent criminal
investigation into what happened Ottawa
says Iran has committed to continue
cooperating with Canada and the other
grieving Nations but there are no
specific commitments from Iran in terms
of those requests from the working group
Donna okay Abigail Beeman in Ottawa
thanks
Iran is facing intense pressure
including from its own people many of
those who died were Iranian or dual
citizens today the country's supreme
leader made a rare appearance at Friday
prayers 80 year-old Ayatollah Khomeini
called for national unity and launched
into the usual anti-american rhetoric as
Redmond Shannon reports lots of Iranians
want him to step down and this was his
attempt to shore up support after recent
protests against the regime this was a
show of support from those fully behind
Ayatollah Khamenei the supreme leader
spoke at Tehran's masala mosque for
Friday prayers for the first time in
eight years oh yeah on recall ye these
American clowns he said who with lies
and utter evil say they stand by the
Iranian people they should see who the
Iranian people are commonly referring to
US President Donald Trump's recent tweet
in Farsi supporting Iran's
anti-government protests ahead oh yeah a
on the downing of flight 752 Khamenei
said the West was delighted the tragedy
diverted attention away from the US
killing of Iranian commander Qasem
Soleimani he also said Britain France
and Germany are just lackeys of the US
and their dealings with Iran and the
anti-nuclear proliferation deal across
the border in Afghanistan a ceremony for
the first of its citizens to be
repatriated Ukraine expects all of its
eleven victims to be repatriated on
Sunday nine of whom were crew members
Global News understands a ceremony will
be held in their honor in the capital
Kiev
Ukraine's foreign minister vadym priest
ICO said Iran is now ready to hand over
the black boxes for analysis and
demanded that happen immediately crystal
was among the team of five foreign
ministers who agreed on a framework of
action at the Canadian High Commission
in London on Thursday Stossel dr. sondik
nominee he said it won't be enough if
Iran only prosecutes the soldier who
pressed the button everyone involved he
said must be held to account Redman
Shannon Global News London
ukrainian president vladimir zalenski
has rejected his prime minister's offer
to resign after leaked audio emerged of
him saying zalenski knows nothing about
the economy the Prime Minister claims
the recordings were doctored but offered
his resignation to show respect for the
president zalinsky has called the
situation unpleasant but is allowing the
prime ministers to stew
stay on he's given investigators two
weeks to determine how the audio was
leaked saying it's a matter of national
security a new book is providing insight
into an extraordinary day in Washington
the day the book claims the American
president called his top national
security advisors dopes babies and
losers the book is called a very stable
genius it was written by two Washington
Post reporters and it recounts a meeting
in July of 2017 inside a secure room in
the Pentagon called the tank it claims
three top officials former defense
secretary and four-star general Jim
mattis former top economic advisor Gary
Cohn and former Secretary of State Rex
Tillerson were concerned about Trump's
impulsive decision-making and lack of
knowledge of history geography US
military strategy and diplomacy so they
put together a tutorial on the basics
according to the Post Trump became
impatient and began to complain at one
point he apparently questioned why the
u.s. couldn't get oil as payment for
American troops stationed in the Persian
Gulf
he said we spent 7 trillion dollars
they're ripping us off and where is the
effing oil on the war in Afghanistan
Trump said to his top military generals
you are all losers you don't know how to
win anymore he then said I wouldn't go
to war with you people you're a bunch of
dopes and babies there was the book
claims stunned silence in the room it
was immediately after that meeting that
Tillerson is reported to a cold Trump
and effing [ __ ] Tillerson mattis and
Cohn of all since left the Trump
administration a Saskatchewan man has
been found guilty of defrauding people
of several thousand dollars that was
donated to a Humboldt Broncos GoFundMe
campaign and Rey Alexia was found guilty
of fraud and possession of property
obtained by crime he started a humble
crowdfunding page shortly after the
Broncos bus crash in 2018 16 people died
13 others were injured when the team's
bus collided with a tractor trailer
alexia go fund me page raised just under
$3,800 almost all of it was deposited
into his bank account he testified he
gave the money to a woman who knocked on
his door soliciting donations for a
Broncos charity a
for an official GoFundMe page raise more
than 15 million dollars and that money
was given to the victims families the
state of Virginia is on high alert
tonight coming up two serious steps it's
taking before a pro-gun rally
US authorities are expanding their
crackdown on a neo-nazi group that
apparently has ties to Canada three more
people have been arrested accused of
involvement in the white nationalist
group known as the base yesterday a
former Canadian Army reservists and two
others were arrested by the FBI it's
suspected they too were connected to a
neo-nazi paramilitary group authorities
believe they were planning to attend a
pro-gun rally in Virginia on Monday and
as Jackson prosecco reports that state's
governor is warning there could be
violence fearing violence
Virginia's capital is on edge fenced off
and under a state of emergency ahead of
a pro-gun rally Monday we are seeing
threats of violence we're seeing threats
of armed confrontation and assault on
our capitol Thursday the FBI arrested
Patrick Matthews a former Canadian
military reservist along with two other
men all three are alleged white
supremacists and may have discussed
traveling to the rally for America's
Martin Luther King Day holiday there's a
lot of rhetoric that get these groups
news a lot of it is aspirational but
there's a small minority within this
universe of hate that will take action
and that's what the FBI is trying to
prevent Matthews went missing from
Manitoba last summer and is alleged to
have crossed into the US illegally in
court prosecutors showed pictures of
some of the men at a firing range they
say the suspects belong to a neo-nazi
group called the base and had amassed
hundreds of rounds of ammunition and had
built their own assault rifle three
other men in Georgia with ties to the
same group were also arrested is it a
threat absolutely it's a threat it's
every bit as threatening as what Isis
might what to do in the coming months
officials in Virginia Fuhrer repeat of
the deadly unite the right rally in
Charlottesville where a woman was killed
as white nationalist marched on the city
in 2017 this time around new state laws
restricting gun ownership have fueled
hatred there's so much tension
the governor has temporarily banned all
weapons near the state capitol building
further angering rally organ
the governor is trying to take away our
ability to carry guns how how ironic is
that how crazy is that
he keeps poking the bear by arresting
people before the event officials are
sending a message about how closely
they'll be watching Monday's rally
fearing civil unrest could play right
into the hands of those who seek to
cause it
Jackson Prosecco Global News Washington
coming up I speak with a reporter who
first exposed Patrick Matthews story
Ryan Thorp tells me how he infiltrated a
white supremacist group
you are watching global national
[Music]
getting inside the world of neo-nazi
paramilitary groups is not for the
faint-hearted so when Winnipeg Free
Press reporter Ryan Thorpe began
investigating recruitment posters that
were spotted in Winnipeg last year he
didn't know where it would lead turns
out it led to a man who was just
arrested by the FBI in the United States
Patrick Matthews disappeared from his
home in Bossier Manitoba in August of
2019 after police raided his home and
seized firearms he's now in custody in
the u.s. it was Ryan thorpes reporting
that first exposed Matthews and Ryan
joins me now from Winnipeg Ryan you
spent weeks working to infiltrate this
group called the base and you eventually
met Matthews what was he like what was
he planning he was he was it was a
strange individual when I met him in
person in Winnipeg I certainly got the
impression that this was someone who
took his political views quite seriously
he was openly discussing the possibility
of carrying out attacks to perpetrating
violence against activists things like
that so I was incredibly concerned by
his rhetoric and then the obvious
question was you know just how serious
was he about the things that he was
saying I think what we saw coming out of
the u.s. yesterday in terms of the
firearms and the stockpile of ammunition
that he was arrested with it points
clearly that you know he was very
serious about these professed views you
know what more do you know about him he
lived in a small town in Manitoba do we
know how he got involved in this what
his family situation is yeah his
family's also from Manitoba I know he
has a brother that is also in the
Canadian Army Reserves in terms of how
he got involved with this he appears to
have undergone a process of
radicalization over several years he
kind of walked me through his I guess
political trajectory when we met in
person going from something of a
libertarian at one point to what he
called a racial realist be a racist
until eventually he got to a point where
he adopted a neo Nazism and actively
beginning trying
to turn other members of the Canadian
Army Reserves who he worked with on to
new Nazism as well you know his story
would likely not have come to light
without your reporting does it suggest
to you that there are others like him
flying under the radar yeah III think
that's safe to say
the military's own report on this which
was released last year indicated that
over the process of several years there
had been 56 I believe members of the
Canadian Armed Forces who had either
been tied to expressing extremist views
or who were bonafide members of hate
groups now at the same time that this
report was being produced Matthews was
flying under the radar so we know that
they're not entirely aware of just how
many folks in the Canadian Armed Forces
hold these views interactive and hate
groups obviously this is a small small
minority of people we're talking about
it doesn't reflect upon the vast vast
majority of folks who serve in the
Canadian Army but I think it's safe to
say that even one extremist in their
ranks is to many because we've
consistently seen that it only takes one
lone actor motivated by these ideologies
to cause a lot of violence Ryan this
guy's been arrested by the FBI he's in
custody in the US now I know you're
continuing to follow the story do you
have a sense of what happens to him next
well he was arraigned in court yesterday
he's facing two separate charges both of
them firearms related if he is if he's
convicted on both counts and sentenced
to maximum sentences he could face up to
20 years in US federal prison all right
well thanks for your reporting on this
Ryan Thorpe from the Winnipeg Free Press
appreciate ography to the next this
bachelor's bid for someone to love to
the moon and back
a mystery in the art world has been
solved more than two decades after a
masterpiece went missing this painting
was found concealed inside the walls of
an Italian art gallery a gardener
clearing away ivy discovered it
experts have confirmed it is the
original portrait of a lady by Gustav
Klimt the piece went missing from the
same gallery in 1997 and police are now
working to find out who stole it and
whether it ever left the grounds well
you may have to suspend your disbelief
for this next story a Japanese
billionaire is looking for a female life
partner nothing unusual about that but
here's the thing he wants to take her on
the first SpaceX tourist trip to the
moon and his microwave reports he's been
busy searching for the right woman it
was only a year ago much of the world
was introduced to the first moon
tourists I am thrown Thapa first
impressions are everything and you say
kumazawa
a skateboarding kid with dreams of being
a rock star who ended up as a
billionaire fashion entrepreneur came
across as earnest if not eccentric he
announced that he hadn't just bought a
seat on Elon Musk's yet-to-be-built
starship he bought all of them and his
dream was to invite artists including
painters musicians and dancers on the
trip to inspire them to create something
beautiful I don't write being long so I
want to share these experiences and the
things we thought that many people as
possible but a year later it turns out
misawa isn't just a billionaire he's a
lonely billionaire and he's now promised
one seat to his life partner whom he
hopes to find through a reality daily
show his criteria a bright and positive
woman who's at least twenty years old
and values world peace twenty seven
thousand seven hundred and twenty two
women ultimately applied now they have
to fill out an online form and submit a
picture but they also have to answer
some key questions if you wrote in a
private jet where would you go are you
motivated by misawa's money and how
would you react if Misawa passed wind in
front of you blame someone else so there
you have it a trip to the moon is
unattainable for most of us
unless of course you're a talented
artists or the future life partner of a
quirky yet seemingly fun billionaire to
the moon Electra Lake Global News
Toronto least he's got the seem song
that his global national for this Friday
I'm Donna freezin tonight's here Canada
is hogsback Falls in Ottawa we'd love to
see your Canada please email it to us
and thanks for watching
Robin Gill will be here at the anchor
desk over the weekend and I will see you
back here on Monday have a lovely
weekend bye-bye
you